et maintenant basso blind test
et aux platines j'accueille dj jack ni
ça doit vous connaissez le principe je
veux l'interprète évidemment me dites
pas le titre de la chanson ça sert à
rien dans un premier temps joue par
équipe l'équipe de laurent baffie contre
l'équipe d' alexandre brasseur voilà et
puis après ça sera le chacun pour sa
gueule tu es prêt jack est ok attention
première chanson
c'était will smith qu'il l'a dit c'est
toi je pense la première mois non tu les
mains non ici c'est toi c'est ta carte
attention c'est bon ça non non je pense
qu'il vaut mieux pas savoir un attention
jaqee ouais ouais
j'avais deux points pour l'équipe d'alex
embrasseurs zéro point pour l'équipe de
laurent baffie
il le mérite attention jaqee à la la la
la en même temps un bail à voir serge un
petit tension
sabri
catherine barma qui est l'autorité
suprême dans cette émission dit barbara
donc ça fait 3 points pour l'équipe
d'alexandre à feurs c'est une gagneuse à
bientôt de karachi la marge
allons-y kaki
les frais
pas de paris
comment
oui
les vols de et vers dit bravo
l'adedy a balancé une première confiance
ce rejet bon ben ça fait un point pour
l'équipe de quatre points pour l'équipe
d'alexandre
la ville la confiance aux gens voilà non
mais j'avais dit avant ça c'est bon
c'est sûr encore attention jaqee
alors john george et à paris je crois
que c'est le 3 juillet donc faut y aller
voilà c'est tout parce que mon avis
c'est la dernière fois qu'on le voit si
je continue oui c'est vrai mais
attendant l'examen oui alcoa déjà qu'ils
continuent
oui
haha
bravo divan respect absolu là à wendy
and sister sledge we are family
oui à fin mai les parfaits bravo alors
on continue
jacky non non
honteux
de ce fait
john thain bravo leur attention
jack
m
attention jaqee
et
oui
ben je vais
bravo l'ont donc ça fait quatre
pointures montrent bien laurent juge dit
loeb
excuse moi roger excuse-moi françois
mais il était otage mais il a trouvé
dickens pêcher là bas au boisé 79 jours
heidi krieger m'a alors dit jack
à
mais
parce que je sais qu'il sait mais elle a
été forte le petit la série à l'as dit
un bon ben ça fait 6 laurent été battue
de paris n'ont pas gagné encore jaqee
c'est mon tournoi
m
the reflex dirhams durant bravo laurent
baffie vraiment excellent et maintenant
on continue
jaqee
ouais
billy paul bravo on continue jaqee td
le point bas là
voilà si vous soufflez là le point bas
là si vous soulevez là c'est tant pis
pour toi ce que la vie est injuste moi
là parce que la vie est très injuste
allons-y jack
oui
bravo laurent rita mitsouko and i
attention jha qui aurait pu le dire même
oui
sortie avec monique parfait attention
jaqee oui oui
oui
legname ans
quoi voir n' ya maintenant
voilà
des coûts
j'avais dit quoi le point bas là
alors 8,8 je vais être obligé de
départager les deux équipes je cherche
un petit peu sur mon sens pleure je
crois que j'ai trouvé
vous allez me dire qui est l'interprète
de cette chanson attention c'est moi qui
joue
reprise de rang reprise de miriam makeba
pas kpata capital par sylvie vartan bien
entendu donc voilà grâce à ce dernier
point
laurent baffie est à neuf et les kids
alexandre brasseur à 8,12 bravo de très
bien défendu parce que laurent est
coriace
non là c'est l e par équipe
maintenant on arrive au chacun pour sa
gueule
pourquoi parce que la vie est injuste
laurent et non à la bombe ou s'avèrent
plus à vous est décontractée maintenant
vous êtes plus être soumis à la pression
de laurent baffie tout le monde peut
répondre tout le monde peut marquer des
points vous aussi
grichka his gun bon non mais sérieux
alors on va y aller je crois un jack il
a le banco le bon bout
je vois serge que un petit labrador
bah non c'est pas un jeu brasseur
catherine barma catherine barma qui est
l'autorité suprême de cette émission me
dit c'est ma fille
on est plutôt laurent et généreux un
demi point
on gagne ensemble on l'a 10 ans voilà
non mais vraiment voilà mon mac
attention jack situé près attention joue
proche la guitare continue de ta mort
ouais jacquot de ma passe
les
la whey je vous évite pas soufflé vous
savez je suis je suis vraiment
intraitable je crois que vous ne
connaissez mal vraiment je suis
intraitable donc là on en est où la
houlala baffie alexandre daf y avait là
vraiment on est dans le oui donc tout va
bien tout va jouer sur le méga banques
ou mais en même temps il est super dur
je n'ai pas beaucoup ça m'étonnerait que
troublant jeu même pas si quelqu'un va
trouver ici
franchement on connaît mais c'est dur à
trouver oui bon on va voir sinon ses
chances et laurent bon on y va de jacky
nathan
oui toi
ouais bravo
allez
non
voilà non franchement tu le savais pas
normalement elle n'aurait pas retrouvé
je n'aurais pas trouvé les gens sont
répartis au québec ou encore un petit
bout elle est formidable cette chance
ah ah
y en a
ça c'est le disque et de jaqee le byblos
la compil du byblos
voilà merci jack lui merci à tous merci
aux jeunes assis à tous bah c'était tout
le monde en parle non attends je vais
peut-être passer pour un con mais j'ai
pas bien compris ce qu'il y avait avant
de prendre deux minutes juste pour
préciser en une phrase y avait quoi
en france il y avait calcul il y avait
en fait tu aurais m3320 contrat non non
non non en mathématiques
en fait on n'invente jamais rien on
découvre dans des bus par le meilleur
non c'est vrai en mathématiques on ne
fait que découvrir et en réalité ce
fameux théorème donc fallu d'autres j'ai
pas été blessées mais seuls le poêle à
bois tombe après j'ai pas alors on
revient
c'était tout moment par la semaine
prochaine le monde en parle je suis sur
les plages du débarquement avec mes amis
jean teulé est mon ami michel drucker